the Supreme Court is weighing the fate
of a man sitting on death row right now
and whether racial bias played a role in
a previous trial
Curtis flowers has been tried six times
for quadruple murder but he maintains
his innocence the Supreme Court heard
oral arguments in the case of flowers
versus Mississippi yesterday and judge
Clarence Thomas asked his first question
in three years making the case even more
notable our Jan Crawford is outside the
Supreme Court this morning with more on
this Jan good morning good morning well
for thirty years the Supreme Court has
been clear you can't remove people from
juries based on their race but defense
attorneys say that is exactly what
happened in Curtis flowers is six
different trials now the first five
either were overturned or ended in a
mistrial now the Supreme Court is way
whether or not race was a factor in his
sixth the justices said they were
disturbed and troubled by the
prosecution of Curtis flowers who's been
sentenced to death for the 1996
execution-style murders of four people
inside a Mississippi furniture store all
six trials were prosecuted by District
Attorney Doug Evans who eliminated all
or almost all of the prospective black
jurors every time the killings rocked
the small town of Winona
last year the Kabaddi award-winning
podcast in the dark examined flowers
different trials finding the 61 of 72
jurors in his six trials were white in a
County that's about half black and every
white juror when he was convicted voted
guilty Evans told the podcast he was
confident of flowers' guilt that I will
answer definitely no question at all the
families of the victims said in a
statement we are confident the right
person is behind bars but flowers lawyer
Shari Lynn Johnson told the justices his
conviction was tainted Doug Evans began
jury selection in flowers 6 with an
unconstitutional and in mind to seat as
few African American jurors as he could
in that sixth trial in 2010 flowers was
convicted in the state Supreme Court
upheld the death sentence saying this
time Evans had reasons not related to
race for striking the prospective black
jurors the justices liberal and
conservative weren't persuaded justice
Elena Kagan the numbers are staggering
just as Brett Kavanaugh you can't just
assume that someone's going to be
favorable to someone because they share
the same race Justice Clarence Thomas
asked a rare question he suggested that
after trial lawyers on both sides had
race on their mind because flowers as
lawyer had struck only white jurors but
Justice Sonia Sotomayor pointed out that
that's because that's all that were left
prosecutor Evans has struck all but one
of the black jurors we expect a decision
in May or June